[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 se joue souhaite une
très bonne année surtout on l'espère
beaucoup de sport en 2021 c'est parti
pour le sommaire de ce à magazine
cyclisme le paris-nice partira des
yvelines en mars prochain pour la
douzième année consécutive cette année
ce sont les communes de saint cyr
d'école et 2 - ville sur mons y en a
qu'un qui ont été choisie comme ville
départ départ les détails dans cette
émission football nous recevrons dans ce
magazine club de conflans pour parler de
la coupe de france dernière équipe il
vit noise encore en lice dans la
compétition
nous reviendrons notamment sur la
formule inédite proposée par la
fédération française pour permettre à la
compétition d'aller jusqu'au bout tennis
coup de projecteur sur l'un des sportifs
à suivre cette année son nom antoine
bibeau d'eau la pépite illinoise a
participé en 2020 à roland garros
juniors focus à suivre l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces thèmes une
information cyclisme sur piste hier soir
sur france télévisions grégory baugé et
neuf fois champion du monde quatre
médailles olympiques dont trois en
argent a annoncé vouloir mettre un terme
à sa carrière
le pistard originaire de maisons
laffitte n'ira donc pas aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo l'été prochain le
sportif de 36 ans estime qu'il n'est
plus à 100% pour un tel événement
grégory baugé avait notamment brillé en
2015 dans des championnats du monde sur
piste au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
il avait remporté deux médailles d'or
lors de ce rendez vous on continue à
parler à cyclisme mais sur route cette
fois ci à c'est désormais une tradition
dans les yvelines la course cycliste
paris-nice passera une nouvelle fois à
part le département au mois de mars
cette année ce sont les villes de saint
cyr l'école et de roiville sur mon chien
qui ont été choisie comme ville départ
les détails
un montage de à rémi lefebvre l'histoire
d'amour entre les yvelines et paris nice
continue pour la douzième année
consécutive le département va accueillir
la course au soleil en mars prochain
le parcours a été officiellement dévoilé
ce mercredi 6 janvier
et cette année c'est la ville de saint
cyr l'école qui ouvrira cette édition
2021 pour une étape à travers les
yvelines le départ de l'étape sera
au niveau de l'école l'école militaire
après on fera une boucle de 2 60 70 km à
parcourir deux fois et donc l'arrivée
sera sera jugé en faux-plat montant
dans le coeur de ville pas très loin de
la ligne de départ mais en coeur de
ville en léger faux plat donc en venant
de versailles donc un clin d'oeil aussi
au château de versailles en passant
et puis une belle arrivée ou et c'est ce
que disait en faux plat montant
le lendemain le peloton s'élancera de la
commune de watteville sur mansion dans
le nord du département pour une étape de
188 km en direction du loiret une grande
première pour ce village de 1000
habitants situés dans le parc naturel
régional du vexin français très bons
cadeaux noël voilà même si noël vient de
passer une journée c'est vraiment un
très très beau cadeau de noël et et on
va se faire un plaisir collectivement et
individuellement un grand plaisir pour
celui là si on va mettre tous les moyens
qu'on peut on peut avoir une autre vie
je trouve que c'est bien la
démonstration que c'est pas que les
grandes communes dans les yvelines qui
font les yvelines les petites communes
les communes moins peuplées une
participent
la commune pourra voir des stars du
cyclisme français et international le
slovène primoz through glitch deuxième
du dernier tour de france a déjà annoncé
vouloir ouvrir sa saison par ce
paris-nice 2021 vous l'avez vu pendant
cette conférence de presse christian
prudhomme le directeur du cyclisme chez
à etsaut étaient présents pour présenter
et détailler cette course nous l'avons
rencontrée quelques minutes après la fin
de cette conférence c'est notre
interview express
[Applaudissements]
nous avons avec le département des
yvelines des liens de confiance et
d'amitié désormais puisque nous partons
depuis 2010 pour paris-nice les yvelines
sont terre de cyclisme pour le haut
niveau
paris-nice le vélodrome à saint-quentin
l'optique des jeux olympiques avec en
plus le bmx et le vtt et puis aussi
formidable notamment dans la vallée de
chevreuse pour la pratique du cyclisme
pour tout à chacun
en ce début du mois de janvier 2021 nous
allons moins d'indications de la part
des équipes sur les coureurs qui seront
au départ parce que la pandémie est là
parce que ils n'ont pas pu établir leur
planning de course avec les coureurs qui
seront dans telle ou telle épreuve dès
maintenant et parce que par exemple pour
certaines équipes ne peuvent pas
récupérer aujourd'hui leur courage
sud-américains ou leurs coureurs qui
sont dans les îles britanniques il
n'empêche que le numéro un mondial prime
aux rubriques vainqueur du tour
d'espagne vainqueur de l'un des
monuments du calendrier du mas amiel et
qui a fait figure de vainqueur du tour
de france pendant plus de dix jours
alors on découvrira par nice le mois de
mars avec lui il y aura d'autres
coureurs de grande qualité je pense
notamment aux
vainqueur du giro guegan art
le jeune britannique qui sera là je
pense aussi à jay z qui était l'une des
révélations d'australiens d'une giraud
également et puis il y aura là des
baroudeurs ou type de philippe gilbert
dans ce cas champion du mans mais il y
aura quasiment les meilleurs sprinteurs
de la planète
c'est un paris nice qui dans son
organisation ressemblera très
vraisemblablement à celui de l'année
dernière c'était le début de la pandémie
l'année dernière il est un système de
jauge grâce au département de les
yvelines et aux collectivités
le tout paris nice mais des yvelines
nous avions pu nous adapter il y avait
des choses qui ont changé
3-3 système de jauge différents pendant
pendant les huit jours de la course
c'est une dernière étape qui n'a pas eu
lieu bref nous avons évidemment plus que
l'espoir d'organiser l'épreuve complète
cette année mais avec ces mesures de
gestes barrières de distanciation le
système de bulles bref nous devrons nous
adapter nous allons maintenant parler
des jo de 2024 bonne nouvelle pour les
sites yvelinois ils ont tous été
confirmée par le comité d'organisation
le département accueillera au total
cette discipline sportive dont du
cyclisme sur piste du vtt ou encore de
l'équitation les détails dans ce
reportage en montage de xavier gens
c'est officiel les yvelines vont
accueillir cette discipline sportive
pendant les jo de 2024 et sites ont été
définitivement adoptée le 17 décembre
dernier par le comité d'organisation
versailles organisera le cyclisme sur
route à proximité du château ainsi que
des épreuves de pentathlon moderne la
ville royale recevra également les
épreuves d'équitation un temps pressenti
à la mode devront nous on savait que
toutes les chances étaient avec nous
parce que c'est un site totalement
exceptionnel et puis l'environnement à
saint quentin en yvelines le vélodrome
nationale accueillera bien le cyclisme
sur piste et recevra les preuves des
scream du pentathlon moderne à une
centaine de mètres les courses de bmx
seront organisées enfin le golf national
recevra les épreuves golfique six ans
seulement après la ryder cup 2018
ce qu'est le bien par rapport aux jeux
olympiques ce que ça va toucher
certainement une
on va dire en public un petit peu plus
large que la ryder cup parce que la
ryder cup
peut-être que ça a touché uniquement le
public d'avertis de golfeurs alors que
les jeux olympiques
peut-être touché des personnes qui
peut-être sont pas susceptibles de
penser au golf alors en tant qu'activité
olympique
enfin la colline d'elancourt et ses 230
mètres d'altitude accueillera les
épreuves de vtt en 2024
une nouvelle attendue depuis de longs
mois par le bce skyteam vous sert le
club local qui organise chaque année la
revancharde une compétition cycliste sur
le site
c'est nous honoré parce que ça fait 25
ans bien qu'on reconnaît sur ce terrain
là il a fait la première revancharde
on est les seuls utilisateurs qui vont
nous vtt ici en compétition et pour nous
c'est une grande réussite c'est un
bonheur un bonheur partagé par tous les
adhérents du club les yvelines sont
aussi hautes de 2 sites paralympiques le
para équitation sera programmée dans le
parc du château de versailles et le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
les épreuves de paracyclisme sur piste
de la voile à présent le skipper louis
burton est toujours en course sur ce
vendée globe les sportifs originaires de
rambouillet a passé avec son bureau
vallée le cap horn pendant les fêtes et
il est maintenant au large du brésil
au classement l'événement est
actuellement 5e à moins de 400
kilomètres du leader yannick bestaven le
navigateur enregistré cette vidéo pour
expliquer sa situation au regard des
[Musique]
et la bonne heure
importe la dépression
la crise des bricolages home away louis
burton devrait arriver dans deux grosses
semaines aux sables d'olonne pour
boucler son tour du monde
changement de décor à une autre aventure
est en train de se dérouler en ce moment
en arabie saoudite le dakar 2021 2 heavy
noah participent à ce rendez vous jean
pierre gars en 57 ans originaire de
montesson et le copilote de christian
lavieille chez md rallye sport c'est sa
22e participation
il ya également jean pierre strugo / ph
sport le pilote de 74 ans est lui
originaire de chatou a découvert le
dakar en 1985 jean pierre garcin est
actuellement 10e du classement général
et jean pierre strugo et 34e cette 43e
édition se terminera ce vendredi 15
janvier
la compétition est particulière cette
année avec le décès de hubert auriol ce
dimanche à l'âge de 68 ans légende du
dakar avait notamment emporté l'épreuve
à trois reprises avant de devenir le
directeur de 1995 à 2004
nous allons maintenant parler d'une
autre aventure celle de la coupe de
france de football cette édition 2021
sera décidément il est dit pour tenter
d'organiser jusqu'au bout la compétition
vu le contexte sanitaire et le retard
accumulé
la fédération française a décidé de
revoir la formule il y aura d'un côté
les clubs professionnels et de l'autre
les clubs amateurs
les deux parcours fusionneront au stade
des huitièmes de finale au lieu des 32e
de finale comme d'habitude dans les
yvelines
un seul club est encore concernée par
cette coupe de france et le club de
conflent qui doit affronter au 6e tour
le club de vitry chats les deux équipes
aient évolué en r1 pour nous parler de
cette situation nous recevons sur ce
plateau l'entraîneur car la prison et le
défenseur sofiane eychenne toof bonsoir
bonsoir alors car le prison qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce calendrier
écoutez
les la fédé parce que c'est la fédé qui
sont occupées c'est de faire le maximum
pour qu'on puisse être dans les
meilleures conditions afin de pouvoir
continuer la compétition mais ça c'est
compliqué parce qu'on est dans le flou
et tant qu'on n'a pas de date
eh bien on a du mal à se projeter vous
vous projetez vous aussi au niveau des
joueurs
bah oui comme on vient on s'entraîne
mais bon il n'y a pas de réel objectif
comme on n'a pas la date
on sait pas pour quelle période où on se
prépare quoi ça se passe comment le
quotidien le quotidien on a essayé de
reprendre fin novembre or pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée on l'aura elle
pourrait téléspectateurs vous avez reçu
fin fin octobre en octobre ou pour ce
match de coupe de france qui devait se
dérouler comme innovant soit c'est ça
donc après les mesures sanitaires du
gouvernement on a fait comme tout le
monde un confinement
donc on a repris à partir du 28 novembre
à partir du 28 novembre par petits
groupes
une petite préparation on a commencé à
accentuer parce qu'on était un petit peu
optimiste aussi sur la situation
donc on s'est dit qu'on allait jouer
peut-être début janvier
cette coupe de france sur le premier
week end de janvier parce que c'est ce
qui était prévu
puis finalement ça s'est pas améliorée
et puis couvre feu le 15 décembre
et là on pouvait plus s'entraîner donc
quotidiennement on s'entraîne le
week-end le samedi et le dimanche
on fait beaucoup de jeu mais encore une
fois
on passe dans fou et cette coupe de
france finalement on voit qu'on est
encore dans le flou on pensait peut-être
qu'elle allait se jouer peut-être au
mois de janvier vous finalement on parle
peut-être de février de mars
finalement cette coupe de france il
fallait la lune et peut-être selon vous
c'est finalement une bonne formule ce
que ce que la fédération française a
proposé bras c'est une bonne formule
parce que sa tenue ça nous permet de
pouvoir respirer aller encore plus loin
comme on reste entre clubs amateurs à
peu près et le seul souci c'est qu'il ya
des équipes qui vont pas arrêter
l'entraînement et nous on a arrêté un
peu donc au final on sait pas il y aura
une différence et physiques au bout d'un
moment on parlait de peut-être la nuit
les salles coupe de france car le prix
zoé ce qu'il fallait l'annuler peut-être
savent qu'ils font cela
tant qu'il ya de l'espoir pourquoi
l'annuler après tout le temps avance
plus ça paraît compliqué parce que je
pense qu'une organisation d'abord pour
les les professionnels parce qu'il y en
a qui sont engagés dans les coupes
d'europe tout ce qui va avec
finalement à quel moment on peut
vraiment se projeter pour pouvoir la
jouer cette coupe de france donc est-ce
qu'il faut l'annuler sincèrement je suis
pas le mieux placé pour le dire mais
tout le temps avance ça risque d'être
compliqué un moment donné on est ce que
deadline peut-être je ne sais pas à un
moment où ça ne sera plus possible selon
vous ou qui est un club amateur
c'est très compliqué c'est très c'est
une situation inédite quand même en
personne n'a de réponse
même les instances n'ont pas de réponse
donc nous qui sommes amateurs haut
conflent football club et il est très
compliqué en plus c'est quand même une
compétition qui tient ou les dirigeants
aiment cette compétition elle tient à
coeur note présente par exemple 1 et a
donc elle aimerait qu'on la joue on a
envie de la jouer parce qu on est des
compétiteurs on t'aime dans la tradition
aussi c'est bien c'est sympa parce que
c'est une belle aventure
et puis sur la station aspect sportif
sur laventure qu'on avait mis en place
et qu'on est en train de vie c'est un
petit peu frustrant on pour en revenir à
votre question est ce qu'il faut la nuit
un moment donné tant qu'on n'a pas de
date
on ne peut pas on peut pas se prononcer
non puisque vous hésitez sur un parcours
historique un peu le dire pour le club
il espérait atteindre le tour suivant
vous êtes face à une équipe de vitry qui
est de votre niveau qui en airain vous
auriez pu prétendre à aller plus loin
peut-être dans la compétition c'est ça
tout était possible de citer une équipe
de notre niveau bas sa touche sur le
match et sur un match tout est possible
il ya également du coup ce problème
aussi de public
si c'est une aventure humaine vous
disiez juste avoir justement car le peso
ya souvent dans ces matches de coupe de
france le public qui vient voir
le club de sa ville l'a cette fois ci il
n'y aura sûrement peut-être pas de
public peut-être dans cette prochain
tour de coupe de france ouai il n'y aura
pas public donc après bon ça l'est aussi
en le vivant
donc c'est peut-être plus triste pour
vous clubs amateurs
écoutez oui c'est triste mais après
qu'est ce qui fait qu'un footballeur
c'est la compétition donc au delà du
plaisir du jeu il ya la compétition il
ya le vestiaire donc sincèrement tant
qu'on est sur le terrain on est content
déjà le fait de se retrouver le week-end
à s'entraîner faire du jeu entre nous se
retrouver c'est un réel plaisir
donc après ou donne une date on dit on
joue on va être content après il ya
d'autres aspects qu'il faut prendre en
compte même si on n'y est pas encore
c'est qu'il ya des clubs qui ne se sont
pas arrêtés comme disait sofiane mais
bon là c'est un échelon super puisque
c'est les pros s'il arrive qu'à un
moment donné on se rencontre avec des
équipes professionnelles
il va vraiment une différence de pas
forcément de niveau mais sur l'aspect
athlétique et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut prendre en compte sa fresque
vous n'êtes pas peut-être démoralisé
l'entraînement quand vous allez à
l'entraînement base de ces deux
week-ends ou du coup la semaine parfois
non j'ai toujours un plaisir en fait de
pouvoir se voir remettre un peu
d'ambiance ça fait comme on n'a pas la
possibilité de recevoir la semaine
bah en fait c'est un petit plaisir on
joue on s'amuse
après c'est vrai qu'il manque la
compétition du week-end mais au final
non c'est toujours un plaisir
grâce à ça justement on n'a pas ces
manques de on n'est ce pas les bras
qu'on a toujours un espoir
il y a aussi le championnat vous étiez
deuxième du classement pour l'instant
pas de nouvelles non plus sur la reprise
des championnats on parle de playoffs de
pelé donne peut-être pour
pour les accessions où les montées ou
les descentes justement dans les
championnats est ce que ça pourrait être
une bonne option peut-être aussi pour
raccourcir ce calendrier
après est ce qu'il ya une bonne ou une
mauvaise option le sait pas tant qu'on
n'a pas de date pour savoir qu'on va
reprendre si on va travailler en
fonction de la reprise à partir de là
ils vont pouvoir mettre en place ce
qu'ils veulent à l'heure actuelle
l'instant c'est que des postures une
bonne option parce qu'on a la possible à
la pelade à la passe d'être promet
toujours un espoir en étant 6e donc au
final ça apportera peut-être un petit
peu de suspense car le réseau je sais
pas après c'est c'est une formule qui
est de mettre en place pour pouvoir
finir le championnat épique qui puisse
savoir si on le rappelle ce n'est pas
encore validé non c'est pas validé j'ai
lu un petit peu les circulaires il y en
a tellement qui passe
ça change souvent donc après encore une
fois les instances est de mettre tout en
place pour que la compétition puisse
avoir du sens et oui ça a du sens après
ce que c'est une bonne option
sofiane le dit il suffit qu'on finit 6e
sur les matches aller on se retrouve aux
playoffs et puis après le football c'est
c'est une science inexacte
s'il arrive que sur ce mini championnat
on le gère bien et qu'on en finisse par
remonter
oui pourquoi pas toutes les toutes les
compétitions ont leur histoire et puis
il faudra la prendre comme il se doit
dernière question c'est un petit peu
l'habitude au mois de janvier qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour cette
année à 2021 bah quand ils jouent au
football tout simplement la même chose
même chose j'espère que vous pourrez
jouer au football très prochainement
merci beaucoup en tout cas la trouille
d'être passé sur ce grâce aux bons
poissons vasile de la saison on
continuera évidemment à vous suivre sur
tv à 78 on termine ce 7,8 sport part du
à tennis est l'un des sportifs illinois
à suivre en cette année à 2021 son nom
antoine ghibaudo à tout juste 15 ans le
tennisman qui s'entraîne au comité des
yvelines de feucherolles fait partie des
meilleurs jeunes de sa génération
regarder à son portrait il est l'une des
plus belles promesses du tennis français
à 15 ans antoine ghibaudo fait partie de
la nouvelle génération des tennismen
appelé à briller sur la scène
internationale le tennis une discipline
que le sportif d'un mètre 87 a connu
très jeune j'ai commencé le tennis à
trois ans avec mon père parce que lui
aussi joué
du coup il m'a fait essayer j'ai tout de
suite aimé ça du coup c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé je me souviens que j'ai
tout de suite aimé aimer ce sport très
rapidement thuan s'inscrit dans le club
de sa ville sans léger en yvelines avant
de partir au perray en yvelines
aujourd'hui ce spécialiste des surfaces
dures et fun de rafael nadal s'entraîne
quasi quotidiennement comité des
yvelines de feucherolles en étant
licencié au tennis club des loges à
saint-germain-en-laye la journée en
général c'est
je m'échauffe 30 minutes après je fais
deux heures de tennis je refais deux
heures de physique et deux heures de
tennis après et je finis plus souvent
par la récupération 30 45 me à
l'entraînement payant le sportif qui
sert à plus de 185 kilomètres heure a
été ces dernières années champion
d'europe par équipes est champion de
france
il a également atteint les demi-finales
des petits as antoine bibeau doit
également participer en 2020 pour la
première fois roland garros juniors le
tennisman a été éliminée au troisième
tour
forcément c'est mon rêve de jouer ce
tournoi là on va essayer de les gagner
aussi du coup et forcément c'était
c'était une super expérience j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance de deux points le
faire satisfait
oui
après j'aurais bien aimé
aller plus loin quand même parce que le
but c'est quand même pas de se contenter
d'un une victoire en premier tour mais
décide de gagner les tendres il tomba
comme ça en 2021 antoine gillot a de
grandes ambitions il espère participer
aux différents grands chelems et
notamment roland garros juniors et il
envisage également de disputer les
tournois sur le circuit professionnel
mondial les étapes importantes pour
atteindre son objectif
être numéro un mondial c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve bientôt pour un nouveau
magazine encore une très belle année
2021 très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]